do I ever know really
oh yeah good because we want to talk
about because we haven't talked about it
and is really good [ __ ] the final words
about spoilers or some [ __ ] no let's do
it
what you think just see let's amend me
ask you this season eight in general
what do you think love absolutely love
it there's a lot of haters out there wow
they're like oh the story and all that
I'm like shut the [ __ ] up nothing so
goddamn good episodes 3 & 5 ridiculous
jaw-dropping better than any movie I've
seen in long as done why episode 8 they
said the finale was enough 6 wasn't a
fan but I thought I didn't like it I
didn't leave satisfied right I just I
wanted more you're right I don't like
the way it ended but the season in
general and everything anytime someone's
getting famous or a show's getting real
popular the cool thing to do to get
attention is to hate on it so everyone's
hating on it right because that's gonna
get you attention I thought it was
brilliant man
yeah I rewatched the long night which is
the third one you just mentioned and I I
what I did was I watched also the other
day Lord of the Rings the two towers the
last fight you know because I heard that
there was comparative they were
comparing people were comparing the two
wars and these and things and um got the
long night outshine I mean the game of
thrones was beautiful I mean the CGI is
amazing but what I and people complained
about the darkness of the third one I
liked that I didn't do it felt like I
could experience what they're going
that's very good yourself yeah it felt
real in that way and have you heard the
director yes that's exactly what they
wanted people I go I can't see he's like
they can't see yeah yeah having these
[ __ ] monsters in a carrier yeah I'm
scared yeah and then there was one shot
where Sam Carly is standing there right
and this is when they're attacking right
and he does a thing with his eyes and I
think he's D I think it was just an
organic acting thing that he did what it
was like Doc darting just look at what
the lanes are going out yeah what no
even after the flames are going out now
and then now he hears the
like running toward him and his eyes are
darting it's a it's only a two-second
cut to him right I got the [ __ ]
chills bro yeah you know it was great
acting by him yeah everyone even like
Breann goes holder hold the line she
didn't die yeah but yeah yeah I thought
she was gonna die episode 3 me too yeah
yeah yeah but why because she's in the
front row right right I just knighted
her so I'm like she's going all that you
know we cared about that character so
much she's going yeah but people
complain that not enough characters died
that episode I want it so much when it
ended on like oh my god standing
applause just fine yeah me too me good
I think everyone is so quick to [ __ ] on
it but like I managed my expectations of
the season you have six episodes to wrap
up so much and such a small like those
parameters are very tight so for what
that what they delivered to me was
perfect but also any any angle they go
the reason why you love Game of Thrones
is usually it's pretty unpredictable so
that that unpredictability is what
people like so now in this season if it
doesn't if the narratives not going the
way these people want they get online
and complain yeah but the other negatory
on social media that's just that's what
people do I mean it's what they let me
defend if I post if I post oh man this
is great
you're gonna get a thousand comments
people being negative yeah let me defend
though the people that are complaining
okay I get it
alright you invest it's more than eight
years because they took a two year
hiatus I started I didn't you know how
you binge like four seasons like three
years ago I started eight years ago yeah
my thing that doesn't matter
cool man yeah we saw the same [ __ ] yeah
yeah we use that as a reason as to why
they're more upset than the other other
people like you started two years ago I
think someone who watched it eight years
in yeah I was still perfectly happy with
it yeah but you can I understand that
but I also understand why people are
sad about it because they a lot of
people like you know invested all this
time you know I think people get hooked
on the show because of you know when Ned
Stark gets behead like these these
moments yeah right the red wedding
elements right all the red wedding you
kidding me but also don't get that into
a goddamn show where it affects you in
life you know I'm saying yeah it's great
there's also dragons in it so let's
relax
yeah it's also dry I see what you're
saying people get up so obsessed and
they make it's like my brother got the
tattoo on a jewel of a stork on his arm
it's too much too much yeah and I'm the
one that for him though yeah yeah I
forced him to watch it yeah and then Oh
two weeks later look I love this guy
yeah thing is if Game of Thrones it
there's people have so much invested in
this as fans yeah there's not a senior
they could have done this last season
where people had been stoked no matter
what they did whatever you however you
want to end however you want to however
I thought [ __ ] in doesn't matter they're
gonna piss off this group of people they
can't win in this it's kind of it's kind
of like when they do comic book movies
the nerds are so into it and they have
an idea how they think it should go no
they've never written a script in their
lives yeah they have an idea how they
think it should go yeah so there's so
much hate there's more hate than
anything on comic book movies you think
about you know because I've been in
shitty things I've been some good things
but I know generally how things are shot
I've been on movies you know and I
understand what people's jobs are what
cameras director what everyone does
video village all these the terms the
jib camera you know but like but you
realize even when you're on a shitty
sitcom or a sketch show or something
that there's still many many hours of
preparation right you have props sets
you know right rewrites you know there's
just so much pressure even on something
like a late-night show like MADtv that
was like you know people like running
around like a chicken with her head cut
off trying to figure this out it's hard
right now imagine now with the whole
world watching with millions of dollars
at play right and you're off script from
the book so that base that you started
you gotta branch out to that right so
that's another thing for sure different
animal right so with all those things in
play I that's why I give the showrunners
and an HBO a pass because it's like you
guys did the best you can you could tell
I mean even the last episode even though
we didn't like the way it turned out
right I did I didn't complain yeah I
didn't complain either but here's how I
wanted it to end
murmur Podrick has brand he wheels him
into the council meeting tearing Tyrians
everyone's there right and get on my
nerves
brand the broker people hate that yeah
yeah yeah what'd he make he gets on your
nerves I don't like walking cocky he's
the king now crippled but here's the
thing yeah here's the thing the entire
seven half seasons they're all
everything yeah yeah you know I just
just have to be alive and you're here
exactly where you're supposed to be out
I don't want anything and then they roll
my like do you want to be king yeah well
now you want it I'll get the [ __ ]
maybe you want it the whole way here's
should have saw this is something you
don't even think about my face I'm sorry
my bad here's the thing dude and people
don't talk about it in the show
the guy can't use his dick imagine how
he gets off he has to warg into a pigeon
whatever the pigeons pitch is [ __ ]
and that's how he gets as a [ __ ] off
kind of cool when you think about it
yeah but you but let me say something
gay fees if you're into pigeon [ __ ] are
you into pigeon [ __ ] I don't know never
been right yeah you're not because
they're [ __ ] have feathers in it
that's what makes it greatest ruler
though because of his dick is useless
then it's not gonna drive no but yeah
I'm just saying when he became king I'm
like okay at least give him that think
about it everybody who was a eunuch in
the show grey worm no no but he was
[ __ ] godly for his you know whole
life what I'm saying overkill a little
bit overkill like you know all the
[ __ ] uh you know the Lannister army
or the golden come in there tied up on
their knees right and Jon Snow
[ __ ] jon snow goes hey man you
know just let them go or put them in
prison or whatever you don't know they
deserve any slice of their neck off
that's a little too overkill for me it
was pretty intense
yeah but here's how I wanted to John
snows driving me nuts to this season
such a last few did you just like speak
up his presidential speech before they
burned all the bodies and whose voice
was that was not his voice was it not
lots of weird voice oh yeah that was a
weird voice there wasn't it that was in
a DRS why you said that because when I'm
hard as mr. snow you're right about that
but the way I wanted to end is this let
me fear me out now guys all right the
council's there right prod was at pad
Potter brings bran the broken end they
have a couple of conversations and then
Podrick turns the thing around and takes
him out of the room and then bran
turns around a little bit and you can
see his eye and it's blue I thought he
was and then the end if they ended it
that way we would have all been like
thank you thank you
right we would be like what we wouldn't
slept for a week you know my theory was
and that's [ __ ] brilliant that's a
great kills great my three was was brand
he was showing Jon Snow is all dream
we've been watching this dream because
he didn't want to take the throne so
he's shown him what happens if he
doesn't man the [ __ ] up and take the
throne what should be his so I think
maybe it's a dream I like people can
read piss how are they gonna tie all
this together
I thought maybe that was a because that
the interesting character development
they cut early I'm like maybe they're
doing it because it's a dream gives them
an out yeah that's the how long is this
dream though exactly if it was seven
years of a dream Game of Thrones the
entire dream Brendan get the [ __ ]
yeah but that's interesting because what
you're saying about him being the night
king all that stuff there there are some
things in the show that they fail to
explain right bike make for instance at
the symbol of the you remember like when
a couple episodes ago it was right
before the long night when the wildling
and that other guy from Night's Watch
they tell the boy and the boy was
against the wall and that symbol they
used with all the limbs yeah they show
that symbol a bunch of times you know
don't know what it means
yeah I mean it's more you know it's and
they when they throw something that out
like that outsider like oh this is so
deep because we're gonna figure out what
that all meant you never like really
please you guys upset how Circe's and
how no I like the way she died because
it was a very insignificant death and I
think that's what Cersei deserves yeah I
want I wanted I that's what she wants an
audience to tell her story about how she
died there's still an ego in death and
the fact that she a rock deep girl you
know killed her with no audience deep
cut no yeah then it's like wow that's a
that's a death you deserve with no
audience and no story to tell no one
even [ __ ] find her it was a cool love
love story the way the end is very Romeo
and - how do you think if you were
writing the show how would you a kill
Cersei see I don't know if you give the
area Stark that much power where she I
thought she was gonna kill her but then
what she killed the [ __ ] night king
tonight King and her yeah how much too
much I'll about the Hound yeah the
[ __ ] mountain that was a great scene
when he died by fire but it's also like
like he amber when he that one time when
he was in the woods and he saw the flame
that's how he
basically yes but he wasn't hit the the
mountain wasn't the mountain anymore
and plus the mountain was too [ __ ] human
when he was still not when before he was
Frankenstein yeah I didn't like each
other even before Bruce was that way
yeah I thought about what I would do
this or say and what I would have done
is I would have um tied her up stuck a
glass bottle in her vagina who didn't
have class back yet then but carry on
they they didn't have glass when did you
ever see glass and the entire dragon
glass
no no glass was a rock same sort of rock
and there was a couple of buildings
don't worry I don't I've seen stained
glass windows on some of the buildings I
don't think so there's no windows and
castles bro I don't like your toes get
up and look it I'll [ __ ] it up
back then check out there's me yeah was
there any kind of glass plastic but I
would have taken a glass bottle stuck in
her vagina right and then taking a
mallet and just shattered the glass okay
no vagina killer but okay you know what
I would have done remember how why are
you like this
Oh with the melted head that's how you
melted her let me just watch like yes I
used to looking up the glass yeah this
got us I would have liked for joining
your team bro no what you search glass
Game of Thrones glass
[Music]